[Musique]
redoutez des professionnels comme des
particuliers la mouche des fruits
constitue un véritable fléau pour
l'agriculture réunionnaise depuis son
introduction sur le territoire en 2017
le département participe activement à la
lutte contre ce ravageur de récoltes ce
mardi 11 octobre la collectivité
présentait le fruit de sa nouvelle
expérimentation menée en lien avec la
Fédération Départementale des
groupements de défense contre les
organismes nuisibles et l'association
adase l'augmentorium il y a cinq espèces
aujourd'hui qui sont dans nos viseurs je
dirais pour essayer d'accompagner à la
fois les producteurs de fruits que les
maraîchers dans cette lutte qui doit
être aussi collective et portée par le
particulier le département a donc mené
trois actions la première c'est une
action d'expérimentation donc il y a des
appels à projets qui ont été lancés
notamment pour la lutte plein champ et
le département a succès il y a ensuite
la lutte post-école c'est-à-dire les
fruits qui sont récoltés on a mis avec
le ciroi en place un dispositif pour
pouvoir chaude la mouche avant de
pouvoir vendre le produit et enfin le
troisième expérimentation et là le
département Alice a compétence agricole
à sa compétence d'insertion sociale
puisque nous avons confié un chantier
d'insertion à la sauce qui donc fabrique
des augmentorriums et également n'allais
plus belle de récolte des fruits dans
cette lutte contre la mouche des fruits
donc trois axes trois interventions qui
va donc depuis le producteur jusqu'au
consommateur et le particulier c'est sur
l'exploitation de Monsieur Hoarau à
petite île qui a été présenté ce nouvel
outil de lutte biologique destiné aussi
bien aux professionnels qu'aux
particuliers
qui étanche qui laisse pas passer les
mouches nous augmentons il y a une
ouverture qu'on met les fruits pourris à
l'intérieur bon c'est c'est un éthique
il y a juste un petit grillage en haut
qu'on laisse c'est des micro gays qui
sont vraiment minuscule petit qui peut
passer de l'extérieur à l'intérieur
c'est le micro elle va pondre dans les
œufs de la mouche des fruits dans le
moteur et un micro gap elle peut
ressortir comme étant petit et la mouche
des fruits quand il sera à l'intérieur
il y a pas sauter les plus grosses elle
va mourir quoi l'augmenterium se décline
en deux modèles
un litre pour les particuliers et un
modèle en métal d'un mètre cube réservé
aux professionnels un équipement rendu
accessible au plus grand nombre grâce au
concours financier du Département
[Musique]